الان نعود الى تطورات في السودان ولكن هذه
المره سنركز على اتهام الولايات المتحده
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه بتزويد قوات الدعم
السريعه في السودان بصواريخ ارض جو
باستخدامها ضد الجيش السوداني في القتال
الدائري حاليا مع بدايه عام
ترسخت علاقته باجنر مع قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حميدان محمد حمدان الشهير
بحميتي شرعت باجنر بعد انقلاب المكون
العسكري على الحكومه المدنيه في اكتوبر
تشرين الاول عام 2021 في تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع وقد زار
حميدتي موسكو لتعزيز العلاقات اوائل عام
2022 وذلك بالتزامن مع بدايه حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا ومنذ ذلك الحين توالى انتشار
فاجنر خارج مناطق الجنوب الغربي في
السودان قربه بلده ام دافوق على حدود
السودان مع افريقيا الوسطى حيث تعدين
الذهب
لقد اصبح من المالوف الان تمييز ملامح
عناصر المجموعه بهيئتهم المعروفه عالميا
وهم يتجولون في محيط مدينه بورسودان
الساحليه لكن حضور فاجنر في المشهد
السوداني كان على ما يبدو اسبق من ذلك
فاجاد يد حاميه مما وصف بالاعمال
العدوانيه الامريكيه ضد السودان كان الهدف
المعلن لزياره الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر
حسن البشير لروسيا اواخر عام 2017
الثمن حسب ما قيل وقتها كان وعدا من
البشير بان يصبح السودان مفتاح افريقيا
بالنسبه الى الكرملين بجانب امتيازات
التعديل وبناء قاعده بحريه روسيه على
البحر الاحمر في ميناء بورسودان بوابه
البلاد للتجاره الدوليه بعد اسابيع من ذلك
وصلت عناصر من مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه سبق
لهم العمل في اوكرانيا وسوريا وصلوا الى
السودان ومعهم علماء جيولوجيا روس وذكر
انذاك انهم جاؤوا للعمل في مجال التعديل
عن طريق الشارقه مروي جولد المحليه التي
تعود ملكيتها الى شركه ام انفست الروسيه
منذ اذن اصبح وجود فاغنر في السودان امرا
واقعا وفي ابريل نيسان عام 2018 اي بعد
نحو خمسه اشهر من اتفاق البشير وبوتين زار
يفجيني بريغوجين مؤسسوا ومالك فاجنر
الخرطوم وبعد رحيله تحدثت مصادر عن وجود
نحو 100 من عناصر فاجنر يدربون قوات
سودانيه